[Música]
y
rusia asegura controlar una nueva ciudad
ucraniana a las afueras de donges en la
región del bombas desde el gobierno de
kiev afirman que todavía hay en marcha
una batalla feroz
el escritor salman rushdie permanece
hospitalizado y con respiración asistida
en un centro médico de pensilvania un
día después del ataque con cuchillo del
que fue víctima en el estado de nueva
york el acusado un joven de 24 años se
declaró inocente
se cumplen 75 años de la partición entre
india y pakistán este proceso que separó
a estas dos naciones dejó a millones de
familias alejadas con un trasfondo
religioso y a lo largo de tres guerras
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
informativa en la pantalla de france 24
gracias por continuar con nuestra señal
yo soy juan pupiales comenzamos en
ucrania porque dos nuevos barcos con
granos partieron desde el mar negro y ya
son 16 los navíos ya han salido del país
como parte de un acuerdo respaldado por
naciones unidas los de ese sábado son
dos embarcaciones con banderas de
barbados y de islas marshall que portan
12.000 toneladas de maíz y 3000 de
semillas de girasol ambos partieron
rumbo a turquía país que firmó este
acuerdo con ucrania y rusia en medio de
una escasez de esos insumos a nivel
mundial sobre todo en naciones en vías
de desarrollo
mientras tanto hay versiones encontradas
sobre la situación de pez y una pequeña
población a las afueras de la provincia
de donges en la región del donbass
mientras rusia asegura que tiene el
control total de esta localidad el
gobierno ucraniano afirma que allí
siguen librando pse feroces combates por
otro lado del presidente ucraniano por
los dimensionales quien pidió a europa
que los ciudadanos son rusos no puedan
cruzar la frontera hacia el bloque
comunitario andrés granadillo nos tiene
el informe
cae otro objetivo en la región de done
jets eso fue lo que reportó el
ministerio de defensa ruso que afirma
haber tomado el control de la localidad
de pesca el portavoz del ministerio de
defensa de rusia ígor konashénkov dijo
las fuerzas armadas de la federación
rusa continúan una operación militar
especial en ucrania como resultado del
avance de las fuerzas rusas y prorrusas
pisqui en la república popular de donets
han sido completamente liberada cerca de
cra motors que en la república popular
de donets un sistema de cohetes y mars y
un depósito con municiones fueron
destruidos
precisamente cohetes rusos alcanzaron
crema torch el viernes en la noche
causando la muerte a tres personas y
dejando 11 heridos
alina asegura haber sobrevivido por
estar guarecida en su casa de nombre
es bueno si estuviéramos en la calle no
estoy segura de que pudiéramos hablar
con usted ahora todos los elementos de
los proyectiles están en el patio o el
hecho de que estuviéramos dentro de la
casa no salió visto solo esto
tras los ataques que no cesan y la
guerra que ya completa casi seis meses
el presidente volodymyr selenski insiste
en el bloqueo a rusia ya sus ciudadanos
pues maymó dejarán jason si es que en
primer lugar se debe garantizar que los
asesinos rusos y los cómplices del
terrorismo de estado no puedan usar las
visas en guild y en segundo lugar la
idea de europa en sí misma no puede
destruirse nuestros valores europeos
comunes no pueden destruirse lo que
significa que no podemos convertir a
europa en un supermercado donde no
importa quién venga lo único que importa
es que se paguen las comprensión madre
no ni no pulgar entretanto moscú
advirtió a washington que si eeuu
convierte en ley la propuesta de
proyecto presentado en la cámara de
representantes que pide declarar a rusia
como un estado patrocinador del
terrorismo las relaciones bilaterales se
destruirían por completo no abandonamos
a europa porque miles de peces
aparecieron muertos en el río oder un
importante afluente de europa central
conocido en los últimos años por ser
relativamente limpio por albergar a unas
40 especies domésticas de peces alemania
polonia investigan las causas del
desastre mientras que los expertos
pronostican que podría necesitar años
para recuperar su estado natural arena
villacorta nos amplía es una catástrofe
ecológica miles de peces han aparecido
muertos en el río oder que atraviesa
alemania y polonia lo que ha provocado
advertencias de un desastre
medioambiental
veo a los animales morir ante mis ojos
sé que los pescadores perderán su medio
de vida que los visitantes de nuestro
parque nacional que quieren experimentar
su vida salvaje desaparecerán en unos
años
juntos ambos países están trabajando
para encontrar el origen de la
contaminación creando una discordia
entre ambas naciones
inicialmente los expertos atribuyeron
este desastre a los bajos niveles de
agua y a las altas temperaturas debido a
las recientes olas de calor en europa
pero los primeros análisis realizados
desde brandeburgo detectaron sustancias
tóxicas que podrían proceder de vertidos
de mercurio probablemente de una planta
industrial por la capa es pero no estén
de raíz más información y por supuesto
espero una total aclaración y
transparencia de la parte polaca sobre
lo que ocurrió lo que llevó a este
desastre
sin embargo el lado polaco desestimó las
investigaciones alemanas y dijo el
instituto veterinario del estado ha
completado las pruebas de metales
pesados en los peces descartó que los
metales pesados fueran la causa de la
muerte de los peces se están realizando
más análisis los primeros informes
fueron hechos por los polacos el 28 de
julio pero no avisaron a los alemanes
hasta hace tres días probablemente
porque no se imaginaron que la corriente
iba a arrastrar a los peces río abajo
hasta alemania
el ministerio de defensa de perú dio a
conocer este sábado que dos militares
murieron en enfrentamientos con
remanentes del grupo armado sendero
luminoso esto ocurrió el jueves en la
región de vizcatán en el centro del país
y según el gobierno de pedro castillo
estos choques también dejaron seriamente
herido al líder de esta organización
terrorista para analizar el tema
conectamos con paola augas periodista y
corresponsal de abc quien se encuentra
en la ciudad de lima señora ahogas y
gracias por estar con nosotros el
presidente pedro castillo dice que estas
dos muertes de militares no van a quedar
impunes que supone este golpe para las
fuerzas armadas de perú teniendo en
cuenta que ya el mes pasado otro soldado
murió en un ataque con en esta misma
región
bueno buenos días a todos es un golpe
muy grande a
la facción la última facción de la banda
maoísta sendero luminoso porque no es el
sol no estamos hablando de una zona en
la cual uno puede tomar bus avión o tren
es una zona en la cual no tiene que
llegar primero por río luego unas
caminatas muy grandes y al llegar al
corazón del vrae de este zona de
vizcatán la mejor manera de ver cómo
hacer una batalla es lo más parecido a
lo que fue la guerra de vietnam y eeuu
es una zona boscosa hay montañas y todo
eso ha sido tomado desde fines de los 90
por la familia quispe palomino entonces
hacer este operativo que es una
operativo que mezclan en la aviones a la
marina de guerra y a las fuentes las
fuerzas especiales del ejército
realmente es muy
importante para el estado peruano yo
creo que es independientemente del
gobierno de pero castillo porque estas
operaciones se venían haciendo desde el
gobierno de amos de ollanta humala en el
2011 y lo que significa esta operación
es la operación más importante en los
últimos 10 años en esta zona han muerto
dos jóvenes miembros del comando
conjunto la frase armas lo cual por
supuesto es muy triste y ha muerto uno
el mes pasado pero lo que está pasando
en este momento es que los tiene ahorita
por primera vez a los líderes encima dos
han llegado a uno de los campamentos del
líder de víctor quispe palomino que se
tiene el apodo de jose y han levantado
su digamos han llegado hasta la cama de
él agarrado un arma y realmente es muy
reciente muy optimistas los policías
militares y marinos que están formando
parte de la operación señor gas cuál es
el estado actual de sendero luminoso en
el país cuántos efectivos tienen y cuál
es su presencia en el territorio
esta es la última facción de sendero
luminoso en el perú la muerte de anime
de guzmán que fue hace hace pocos meses
que significó digamos ya la caída
simbólica de esta banda de esta banda
terrorista de corte maoísta que durante
20 años asoló el país y se declaró en
contra del estado peruano cuando a mí me
los manes capturado en 1992 en el
gobierno de alberto fujimori había una
facción rebelde en la selva norte
liderada por artemio y la facción de los
quispe palomino en la zona del vizcatán
y realmente todavía no se no se podía
declarar la derrota del de sendero
luminoso pero si se atrapa a víctor
quispe palomino ya los campamentos que
él manejaba en esta zona donde confluyen
la droga en la hoja de coca la cocaína
las armas y yo creo que allí sí se puede
declarar abiertamente que ella sendero
luminoso como tal
y en una sola era más el país
el análisis de paula
periodista y corresponsal de abc gracias
por haber estado con nosotros
cambiamos de tema como adelantábamos en
nuestros titulares el escritor salman
rushdie sigue con respiración asistida
en un hospital del noroeste del estado
de pensilvania eeuu tras el violento
ataque con cuchillo que sufre este
viernes en un evento literario el
agresor tiene 24 años y se declaró
inocente hoy ante la justicia ampliamos
en el siguiente informe de samuel
salgado
este es el momento exacto del ataque al
escritor británico de origen indio
cuando se preparaba para una conferencia
en el estado de nueva york la policía
pudo someter al agresor de inmediato a
quien identificaron con el nombre deja
de matar quien este sábado se declaró
inocente de intento asesinato en segundo
grado y otros cargos a los que se le
acusa la próxima cita con la justicia
será el 19 de agosto mientras tanto
deberá permanecer en prisión preventiva
tras el ataque el escritor salman
rushdie sigue luchando por su vida en un
hospital del noroeste del estado de
pensilvania al que fue trasladado en un
helicóptero y remitido a cirugía
es un individuo que ha pasado décadas
diciendo la verdad al poder
alguien que ha estado ahí afuera sin
miedo a pesar de las amenazas que lo han
perseguido durante toda su vida
rossi recibió tres puñaladas en el
cuello y cuatro en el estómago su agente
literario andrew wylie dijo que uno de
los brazos del escritor está gravemente
afectado así como su hígado y su ojo
debido a la gravedad de su estado de
salud rossi permanece conectado a un
ventilador
su obra literaria le causó enemigos en
el campo religioso en
1989 irán ordenó la muerte de rost y al
acusarlo de blasfemia
se cumplen 75 años de la partición entre
india y pakistán en este último país
miles de personas se congregaron en la
ciudad de la hora acompañando al ex
primer ministro en gran khan para
conmemorar la fecha el evento terminó
haciendo una especie de acto político en
el que kan hizo un llamado a buscar la
verdadera libertad fue en agosto de 1947
cuando terminó el mandato británico que
india de mayoría hindú y pakistán de
mayoría musulmana proclamaron su
independencia desde entonces ambas
naciones han peleado tres guerras en
medio de millones de familias que
quedaron separadas por esta partición
alí hasan vaca y nació en 1946 tan solo
un año antes de la partición de india y
pakistán tras su independencia de reino
unido su familia era una de las millones
de familias musulmanas que había en
india pero tras la creación de pakistán
tuvo que irse con sus abuelos de loba
delhi dejando atrás por décadas a parte
de sus familiares por fase 7 india en
2014 mi madre estaba enferma en ese
momento fui a conocerla y a mi madre
después de mucho tiempo estaba postrada
en la cama la llevé al hospital y luego
tuve 15 o 16 días con ella muy bien pero
cuando me fui a la india nunca imaginé
que no la volvería a ver cualquier beba
se sala la división de pakistán e india
sigue presente para muchos 75 años
después debido a su gran dureza la
independencia de indias se dio en un
contexto de enfrentamiento entre los
diferentes grupos religiosos y étnicos
de esta nación una tensión que degeneró
en la ruptura del territorio en tres
partes la actual india de mayoría hindú
pakistán de mayoría musulmana y pakistán
oriental actualmente conocido como
también de mayoría musulmana
una decisión que hizo que hasta 15
millones de personas tuvieran que
desplazarse de sus hogares para llegar
al país que reconocía a su religión como
mayoritaria un desastre humanitario que
ocasionó entre 1 y 3 millones de muertos
por hambre y violencia y que se para en
la actualidad a muchas familias claro
hay miles de familias así algunas
impulsadas y otras en más lugares tan
apta clinas buscar que ellas sienten un
dolor intenso por la aportación y su
corazón lo soporta como nosotros de
tutor lista es los gobiernos de ambas
naciones deberían escuchar las quejas de
sus ciudadanos aunque un dolor difícil
de sanar ya que la mala relación actual
entre india y pakistán que se han
enfrentado en cuatro guerras el siglo
pasado ha contribuido a profundizar la
división
así nos despedimos y terminamos esta
emisión informativa en la pantalla de
france 24 pero que desee porque la
información continúa aquí en nuestra
señal y también visiten nuestro sitio
web
france24 puntocom
[Música]